the fairly open-ended military budget
that the president is given by Congress
gives the president an enormous amount
of discretion in power that the
president has the right to to start a
war at his pleasure is just completely
divorced from the original meaning of
the Constitution
let me be clear these terms are not
negotiable the resolution will be
enforced through military action there
is no decision i face as your commander
in chief that I consider as carefully as
the decision to ask our men and women to
use military force presidents often say
that they use their war powers carefully
in sparingly but what does the
Constitution say about the president's
actual role in using military force and
what about the role of Congress which
seems totally absent in the latest Libya
adventure executive war powers have
increased over time how did this happen
and is it a problem presidents are going
to push the envelope they're gonna try
to seize power they're gonna try to
expand their powers as much as they can
gene Healey is a vice president at the
Cato Institute and author of the book
the cult of the presidency which takes a
critical look at the growth in executive
power executive power when you look at
what the framers had in mind for the
presidency it was really comparatively
modest modest office who particularly
compared to what we've got today the
increase was gradual in the 19th century
it's been quite substantial in the 20th
century
Michael Ramsay is a University of San
Diego law professor and has a more
expansive view of presidential War
Powers I do think the president has
significant independent power in foreign
affairs even under the original
understanding of the Constitution a
limited constitutional officer chief
magistrate is what George Washington
used to call it when he referred to the
job but it's grown into this combination
national talk show host Universal fixer
political problems and supreme warlord
of the earth in a way I think it was in
response to the events of the 20th
century most significantly with the
Second World War in particular the rise
the United States is a superpower you
had three presidents that were
particularly important in the
transformation of a limited office into
something much more powerful that would
be Teddy Roosevelt Woodrow Wilson and
FDR history proves that dictatorships do
not grow out of strong and successful
governments but out of weak and helpless
ones by the time you get to the
post-world War two ERA particularly in
the area War Powers Truman essentially
crosses the Rubicon with the Korean
so-called police action where you have a
major undeclared war then that kills
tens of thousands of Americans and has
never authorized by Congress article 2
section 1 of the Constitution says that
the president has the executive power in
18th century terms executive power was
considered to include Foreign Affairs
power Hamilton said that the commander
in chief Clause meant nothing more than
the president was the first general and
Admiral of the United States Armed
Forces generals and admirals are
important they have an important job to
do but they definitely don't get to say
whether and when and with whom we go to
war
9:11 are just weeks away big eyes are 72
the nays are 23 article 1 section 8
language is Congress has the power to
declare war the declare war clause was
interpreted broadly by the framers
Madison said that in no part of the
Constitution was there more wisdom to be
found than in the clause that gave the
powers of war and peace to the
legislature and not to the executive one
significant limit on Congress's total
control over war is in the case of the
United States being attacked Congress
have the power over the initiation of
war the initiation of hostilities once a
war is started by the other side then
the president has the ability to fight
the war without interfering with
Congress's power to start the war the
war has already been started by the
other side I think you want to be pretty
careful about how broadly you want to
interpret the president's defense of War
Powers the phrase if the convention was
that the president had the power to
repeal sudden attacks this idea that the
president gets to decide when another
nation is in a state of war with us that
the president's powers go beyond
repelling the initial aggression and
entering a state of total war with with
a hostile nation you've really got an
exception that kind of swallows the rule
of the Constitution which is that uses
of force in the mean have to be approved
by Congress our war on terror
it begins without kind of but it does
not end there in many ways the changing
face of war has further enhanced
executive power in al-qaeda you've got
this stateless conspiracy that operates
in sixty countries although President
Bush was sometimes derided for
metaphorically talking about the war on
terrorism he was quite right to think of
the action against al-qaeda is being a
war Bush administration officials are
literally argued that America was a
battlefield the war metaphor became so
pervasive that tapping someone's phones
in New Jersey became gathering
battlefield intelligence there's no
question we are at war once again and in
Illinois he was founded living in the US
Senate be put on the record on this I
don't I believe on these we should defer
to the commander-in-chief on short term
immediate situations like this is not
something it's can simply be blamed on
presidents Congress has delegated an
enormous amount of power to the
President and has not resisted
presidential expansions congressmen
aren't by and large are not interested
in being held accountable for big
decisions like whether or not we go to
war they'd rather do constituent service
pass out the bacon and get reelected
when presidents have asserted the
ability to engage in hostilities without
specific approval from Congress Congress
has made minimal pushback from my
Republican point of view president needs
to step up his game with Libya but
Congress should sort of shut up and not
not even though Ramsey reads the
Constitution as granting broad defensive
war powers to the president he believes
Obama has overstepped the line with the
recent Libya intervention
President Obama launching attacks
against Libya in 2011 did not seek any
approval from Congress and in my view
that was not a constitutional action on
the president's part Congress passed the
War Powers Act in 1973 over Richard
Nixon's veto the intent of that act was
pretty clearly to put a check on
presidential wars President Obama's
office of legal counsel say that well
look Congress recognized more or less
that the president gets a free pass for
60 days 60 days expires tonight so how
was his system President believes that
he is acted and has acted consistent
with the War Powers Resolution the
president looks forward to would welcome
support from Congress on this issue
we've had over a hundred occasions where
the presidents have put troops in harm's
way since 1973
and it has really inconvenienced any
particular president George Washington
first in war first in peace George
Washington's vision of a modest
executive officer was left behind by
20th century presidents and the 21st
century has seen two presidents who make
war with little or no regard for the
opinion of Congress so what kind of
constraints if any can we expect on
executive power going forward the
development of jockey power over the
time raises the question of whether we
should regard this as a problem or not I
don't think that development has been
entirely bad is a policy matter it's not
clear the United States could play the
role it currently plays without at least
the the global standing army and the
open-ended military appropriations which
are behind so much of executive power
today the framers were right wise to
recognize that no one man should be
entrusted with such momentous decisions
such power and such responsibility and I
think we've had occasion in recent
history to regret the concentration of
power in the executive branch and I
think we're going to have further
occasion for those regrets and the years
to come